c'est les fans et il révélé l'histoire
secrète de johnny alors vraiment là
reste avec nous parce que c'est
incroyable ce qui s'est passé mais moi
j'y croyais pas ce matin c'est ce qui
fait énormément l'actu cela depuis le
décès de dialyse et on entend tout et
son contraire sur ceux ci se dit sur la
rockstar mais aujourd'hui c'est un scoop
qui fait l'effet d'une bombe qui fait
parler
johnny hallyday aurait eu une liaison
avec une actrice très célèbre voilà donc
s'est révélée dans un livre on ne révèle
pas ici à la télévision c'est marlène
jobert on vous a fait un récapitulatif
de cette histoire on en parle après
puisque l'auteur de ce livre
mathieu alterman est avec nous il y aura
fabien lecoeuvre également qu'il sera
avec nous qui a toutes les infos et bien
sûr bernard montiel et nous dira tout
puisque bernard montiel vous le savez
c'est l'ami des stars
sauf que les stars ne sont pas ses amis
johnny hallyday le roi français du rock
est décédé l'été dernier et depuis sa
mort on le sait les langues se délient
outre l'histoire de l'héritage qui
divise le rail david et sa femme
laeticia se sont maintenant ces
histoires d'amour qui font parler johnny
était un amoureux de l'amour et a eu
beaucoup de femmes dans sa vie
la première sylvie vartan avec qui il
s'est marié en 1965
c'est avec elle qu'il aura le petit
david en 1983 elle rencontre nathalie
baye sur un plateau télé tout de suite
c'est le coup de foudre
ensemble ils auront la petite laura il
se mariera ensuite en 1990 avec adeline
blondieau fille de son parolier le plus
fidèle
deux ans plus tard ils se séparent puis
se remarie deux ans après avant de
divorcer une nouvelle fois sa dernière
femme sera évidemment laeticia hallyday
les aujourd'hui on apprend qu'une autre
femme faisait partie de sa vie et elle
est très connue
on peut lire que l'actrice marlène
jobert aurait eu une liaison avec le
rockeur elle a d'ailleurs confirmé les
propos du livre événement dans gala on
avait des affinités
on n'avait pas besoin de se parler
j'étais très touché
mais cette amitié n'a pas eu l'occasion
de s'épanouir alors selon vous fallait
qu'il a révélé cette liaison secrète de
johnny alors
[Musique]
fallait-il révélé cette liaison secrète
de johnny hallyday dans un livre mathieu
alterman est avec nous vous révéler des
choses très étonnante déjà merci d'être
avec nous vous avez réussi à vous
procurer des ces récits très fort écrit
par johnny lui-même en 97 et vous avez
dit je la surnomme lucie la séductrice
des rock les plus terribles autant de
nos tendres années vu s'il et moi
l'avons signé un pacte pas un pacte avec
le diable
un pacte avec une fait rien d'officiel
tout dans le coeur elle est devenue une
grande dame au talent immense
adulé et respecté mais le plus dingue
c'est que quand johnny lui-même explique
que c'est marlène jobert qui lui a sauvé
la vie c'est ce que vous dites dans
l'air oui mais attention ce n'est pas sa
maîtresse c'est une amitié platonique
très très fort qui va durer pendant des
décennies on retrouve des photos ou
johnny va s'gêner marlène jobert écouté
son album alors que le monde oublie la
bo de marc gaubert comme les grands et
très ami avec elle pour y aller quoi moi
j'adore cet arbre est chanteuse et donc
j'essaie de révéler des choses qui
humanise au maximum johnny hallyday
s'est pas faire du boss pour un truc
trash pas du tout alors parce que mine
de rien après la tentative de suicide
elle m'a aidé à remonter la pente
à l'époque elle voulait vivre avec moi
c'est quand même j'ai refusé je venais
juste de me réconcilier avec sylvie nous
nous sommes revus en tournée au japon à
los angeles toujours incognito une
formidable amitié amoureuse baigné de
tendresse et de nostalgie on a retrouvé
des photos de leur histoire même s'il
était très discret voilà avec johnny
aimart glaubert alors si vous pouvez
boom a nié le cul en régie voilà merci
aux rayonnements ils sont apparemment
partis très loin
alors vous vous êtes vous êtes contre
révélé cette histoire va les régler
parce que tout simplement comme vous le
dites si bien johnny en a parlé en
donnant à pseudonyme à cette femme
s'il a donné de son vivant à pseudonyme
c'est qu'il avait envie de garder un
jardin secret donc au nom de quoi on
irait enlever ce jardin secret alors
même pardonnez moi que vous dites que
c'est marlène jobert or il y à d'autres
non oui oui alors je vous réponds
l'autre nom qui circule je maintiens qui
n'a pas été avec le pont qui cirque
c'est qu'il est notre hymne de johnny
hallyday n'a jamais couché catherine
deneuve jamais c'est une histoire qui
est inventé partie de la moyenne
je vais vous dire très simple j'ai
demandé à marlène jobert nom d'hélène
gaubert ça l'embêtait parce qu'elle est
mariée avec le même homme depuis 40 ans
car bien cinq ans et bon dentiste et qui
avait en fait d'ailleurs les dingos
johnny aussi maille la télé mais j'ai
pas envie que la prochaine fois que tu
chez lui jaubert m'avait dit non
évidemment je n'en n'aurai pas parler
d'un temps bien sûr à la lune chapitre
évidemment alors 20 autorisé à révéler
cette histoire bien sûr bien sûr
alors c'est vrai vous aimez johnny bien
sûr je rends pas fait c'est ça donc vous
pensez que ça va lui faire du bien non
moi ce qui m'intéresse est d'humaniser
maximum johnny est ce que la corde dans
mon livre besoin parce que souvent on
imagine les grandes stars à pusher comme
des gens froid et calculateur
johnny hallyday s'est il a mené sa
carrière comme un joueur d'échecs en
faisant croire qu'il est son truc
c'était les petits chevaux
c'était quelqu'un de beaucoup plus
intelligent qu'à maîtriser sa
communication et j'ai eu envie de
montrer que derrière cette communication
à la rubrique y avait quand même
quelqu'un de très sensible qui a
souffert énormément quand il était petit
les histoires d'amour sa première sa
première sorte d'amour c'est la première
femme qu'il a eu dans sa vie est quand
même mort d'un accident de voiture
à 27 ans dans la scène enfin il n'en
parlait jamais donc j'ai envie de parler
de choses qui montrent que johnny n'est
pas sur un [ __ ] soit 1,5 fois l'or en
euros mais même pendant l'élection de
miss france 2006 ils étaient tous les
deux présents il y avait également
laetitia regardez donc marlène jobert et
johnny lira les magnifiques 1 dans la
durée voilà merci on peut passer vite
les photos merci voilà et donc marlène
jobert est avec johnny dans ça c'est
laetitia merci donc souvent sont moins
moi je trouve que vous pensez que voilà
comme elle le prend marlène jobert elle
vous elle vous aide à vous à dire vous a
donné de ses nouvelles
elle peut pas moi je dis jusqu'à une
amitié très profond bruit ça veut dire
quand même non elle voulait vivre avec
lui c'est par passait pas par hamid
syriennes ont annoncé les années 60 pour
faire on vit avec des gens comme ça avec
des gens qui ont en commun noté sur est
tellement elle était là tous les
anniversaires à chaque fois tous les ans
c'est comme chez come back castaldi il
vivait avec des gens communauté puis les
a épousé
s'assure alors donc dans le public de
demain parce que c'est vrai que là il ya
plein de révélations et dans le public
de demain de nouvelles révélations sur
sébastien farran et laeticia hallyday
sébastien farran qui est donc le manager
tony et qui paraîtra demain on apprend
de nouvelles choses donc concernant
l'ancien manager de doni sébastien
farran il est ici à regarder et ils
disent que les deux sont très complices
donc si on pouvait mettre le public s'il
vous plaît fabien lecoeuvre nous a
rejoint
qu'est ce que ça veut dire cette
histoire entre le manager et et lætitia
ils font la une public sans dire
vraiment les choses
est-ce qu'on peut le voir voilà
sébastien la rend si heureuse teinte et
issia avec son mât d'ailleurs son
manager a passé plus de quinze jours à
ses côtés des noms mais c'est toujours
très subtil la rend si heureuse ya
toujours cette ambiguïté sur le
sentiment amoureux évidemment derrière
ces enfants ont vendu des journaux avant
tout un
je pense que c'est surtout ça alors
certains disaient qu'il avait une
liaison d'autres que non d'autres qui ne
la quitte plus de ces son meilleur ami
voilà c'est si on laisse après le public
juge ou pas de la situation parce que
fox est une loupe à la rend heureuse il
a peut-être acheter un sac à dos et
mathieu non mais la vérité c'est quand
même la deuxième fois qu'il ya une avec
sébastien farran c'est la deuxième fois
maintenant il ya aussi on se souvient
pas mais dans voici et une comme quoi
elle avait été voir un avocat
quelques mois avant qu'on sache qu'il
était malade pour demander le divorce
bref elle aura un amant ce deux fois
qu'on le dit elle a demandé le divorce
si on n'a pas compris en tout cas que ça
se passait mal et qui n'étaient plus
ensemble avant qu'il soit malade c'est
quand même con idiot quand vous crachez
vraiment alors oui moi je rêve dans le
rêve
moi je vous le dit chez moi alors vous
le dis moi moi je pense vraiment qu'il
est temps qu'on sent une attente très
courageuse de l'avoir accompagne jusqu'à
la fin de sa vie et ça vraiment elle a
toute mon admiration c'est très très
bien ce qu'elle a vécu mais je pense
sincèrement qu'ils n'étaient plus
ensemble avant qu'une soeur malade
ah oui c'est surtout un petit coup de
pub que fait une nouvelle fois public à
laëtitia pourquoi parce que laëtitia
évidemment elle est détesté par tout
affronte public veut se mettre à eau
veut faire plaisir à son public
et comme par hasard laetitia heureuse à
côté pendant austral laura on pleure
donc c'est évidemment un nouveau
chapitre dans la guerre qui les oppose
ils veulent flatter encore blick et du
côté de bientôt comme la forme à ce
qu'ils veulent faire des scores
et sans faire de pub lic là vous dites
de grozny qui met à bas comme baba comme
par hasard il faut une ati kodak est
l'heureux celle autre ampleur et
pourquoi ton ami l'a construit l'ancien
pourquoi la france ils ont tué séduit
les français pendant les sessions
contrôle et il est pourquoi c'est pas
les magazines quand je dis ça alors je
restais sur le strict plan de la loi il
ya bien deux tous les vertus du
évocateur la presse écrite
tous les magazines ont des avocats ils
ont de tout s'est pourvue en procès en
revanche si vous quand même s'il est
d'éviter le référé et tout parce qu'il
ya tout un arsenal ce droit-là primé par
la presse mais non mais alors là qui
sont prudents c'est un argument très
important oui très important mais si ya
ce qu'on appelle le droit à l'image
d'accor et à un moment donné c'est pour
ça d'ailleurs souvent les révélations
sur la vie des gens sort après leur
disparition alors juste il n'y a plus
droit à l'image